she's in the battle dimension we have to
go in and get her back Walter
[Music]
you
come on
what else do I have to do but no more
mr. nice Mario if coming down the best
didn't help me find eye on us then maybe
it's time for me to count down as the
worst my name is Walter benezia for
months I was trapped in the evil Dino
Rob's dial dimension a place where I was
duplicated dozens of times eventually I
managed to escape but now Dino Rob is
sending his army to take me back with
the help of my friends he fight them off
and hoped to ultimately take down mr.
rage dinosaur the more we countdown the
weaker he gets this is top-5 the Super
Mario franchise has had many more hits
than it did misses however there have
been some truly awful games featuring
Mario as a main character the majority
of these games have been edutainment but
thankfully we are sticking with the main
franchise so I was not forced to relive
childhood traumas playing Mario teaches
typing it was hard to come up with a
list of the worst Mario games as many of
these games aren't bad so much as they
are just some of the most bland or
puzzling in the main franchise these are
the top 5 worst Super Mario games number
Super Mario Land 2 6 golden coins
this game was Nintendo's second go at
creating a Mario game for the Gameboy
and it was better than the first I guess
the game opens with Mario's castle which
he has now apparently being overtaken
and stolen by an uglier bigger version
of him named Wario Mario must now
collect 6 golden coins to get his castle
back since Super Mario Land 2 is a Game
Boy game it is understandably short
there's only so much that can be done
about batteries running out in the
system dying because it had to be short
the difficulty was also pretty low this
can make the game unengaging
it was a pretty odd and strange game too
although it did feel much more like a
Super Mario game than its predecessor
Super Mario Land which will definitely
come up later in this list overall it's
short and easy but pretty creative and I
will definitely cut this game some slack
for introducing Wario
this is a good work Dino Rob I lasted in
here from what you think you could scare
me oh praise be to turn around to his
tourist processor number four new super
mario bros to the developers of this
game showed that they really knew the
character of mario and what motivated
him wealth and coins weight released for
the 3ds in 2012 the theme of New Super
Mario Bros 2 really is focused on
collecting as many coins as possible
which seems like a mischaracterization
of Mario to top it all off the game did
not change the long-established norm of
a hundred coins giving players an extra
life this resulted in Mario getting
dozens of 1up says he gathered more
coins death truly had no meaning not
when you have 50 lives all of the
challenge and stakes were gone New Super
Mario Bros 2 was just a little boring
and unengaged maybe if it started
another character like Wario I could
have been more invested it's not a bad
game as long as you play it in short
spurts but it's not gonna keep your
attention for too long this game was an
honorable mention last week the world
put that on there
this is about to get crazy I got a
countdown good thing I brought one of my
favorite Mario side-scrollers the new
super mario brothers - I'm 30s I love
this game
number three Super Mario Bros 2 the
history behind this game is a bit
bizarre yet interesting Japanese
executives were concerned that the
American audience would find the
Japanese Super Mario Bros 2 too hard so
instead of releasing that game they took
one of their platformers that had not
been released in the US and essentially
re skinned it to be a Super Mario game
the result while not terrible is
disjointed and inconsistent the original
game was titled Doki Doki Panic and was
a platformer with the theme of Arabian
Nights the game is therefore set in a
world that is clearly not the Mushroom
Kingdom established in the first game
players were allowed to choose between
four playable characters the issue here
was that not all levels were built with
this in mind creating inconsistent
difficulties and level designs in
general many people still have a hard
time accepting Super Mario Bros 2 as a
real Mario game because of its history
this debate could go on forever without
resolve Doki Doki Panic is a solid and
creative platformer it just wasn't an
actual Mario game originally it's a
strange situation to say the least
and diverges from the original source
material number two Super Mario Land in
1989 developers wanted to bring Mario to
the Gameboy and well ride Super Mario
Land was ambitious and that it would be
one of the first handheld platformers
ever it was bound to be plagued with
some kinds of problems
the graphics are tiny and low quality
some of the physics of the gameplay are
off but perhaps one of the main reasons
this game is on the list is its
departure from the Mario identity the
game was developed by gunpei Yokoi and
his team rather than shakira Miyamoto it
was obvious that yoko wanted to do
something new and different from the
traditional franchise which is not
necessarily a bad thing but it didn't
translate while on the Gameboy Mario was
in Sahara Sal and rather than the
Mushroom Kingdom
he was working to save Daisy rather than
Peach
he fought aliens rather than Koopas it
was kind of bizarre Miyamoto's charm and
creativity definitely were missing from
this installment of the franchise Super
Mario Land was also very short
again the game had to be short and easy
enough for people to beat before the
batteries died in their Gameboy in
consistency in quality and design across
levels also plays a large role in why
this game is at the bottom of our list
you cannot hide from judgment blasphemer
you escaped once it shall not happen
again and the number one worst Super
Mario game is Super Mario Bros the Lost
Levels this game was basically just DLC
for the original Super Mario Bros game
another game with a bizarre backstory in
1986 the developers of the original
Mario game had to try to make a quick 9
months turnaround on a new Mario game to
help boost the Famicom disk system it
was released as Super Mario Bros 2 in
Japan it wasn't released in America
until 1993 and was retitled The Lost
Levels the idea behind this game was to
make a much more difficult version of
Super Mario Bros in that quest it added
some unfair game elements such as
poisonous mushrooms and mid-jump
air gusts it can be downright
frustrating to play this game I
understand the developers wanted to give
players a challenge but some of these
levels are ridiculous I would even go so
far as to say I felt trolled by a
Nintendo the first time I played it
there's a difference between being
challenged and frustrated out and this
game definitely leaned more towards the
latter no one wants to feel cheated or
played by their game especially if it's
from franchise you hold dear to you
I will strike down upon thee with great
vengeance and furious anger those who
try to poison and destroy this dimension
who you know the power of the Lord
diamond robbed when ally his vengeance
upon you
[Music]
looks like you've been using some
imagination I'm getting the hang of it
good because we're gonna need everything
you've got to get Ayane back
it's you
[Music]
[Applause]
you